[Music]
113 question about evolution with John
Perry question number one what is life
biology is the study of living things
it's the study of life and you would
think that because biology is the study
of life biologists would have some sort
of a definition for what life is
something that clearly explains what
living things are and what living things
are not but such a definition cannot be
found in a biology textbook they just
skip right over it you might think that
defining life would be easy I mean even
a child can tell the difference between
a cow which is alive and a rock which is
not alive things get tricky though when
you consider things like viruses some
people don't consider a virus to be a
living thing viruses can reproduce they
can evolve but they don't have cells
they themselves are not a cell
they're just genes encased in protein
another really interesting example of
something that we might want to consider
to be alive but a lot of people don't
consider to be alive would be a plasmid
a plasmid is a loop of DNA that gets
inside of bacteria and can actually
control the bacteria temporarily when
the bacteria comes in contact with
another one the plasmid will take over
make it fuse with that other bacteria
and will then go and infect that
bacteria as well so these are really
strange you could call in creatures
maybe they're alive maybe they're not a
depends on who you're talking to depends
on who you're asking but these things
can reproduce and evolve inside of a
living cell independently of that cells
reproduction and evolution very
fascinating in between things because
living things are so complicated and
because they're constantly evolving and
changing some philosophers have said
that it's actually a pointless endeavor
to try and define life there's actually
a large group of philosophers that don't
like it when we try and define anything
that's that's complicated
well a few years back there were a group
of researchers for NASA these were XO
biologists people who are studying the
possibility of life on other planets and
these guys said you know what
philosophers we are going to do it
anyways we are going to come up with a
definition for life and they did
today it's known as the NASA definition
for life and it goes like this
life is a self-sustaining chemical
system capable of Darwinian evolution
let me say that again
life is a self-sustaining chemical
system capable of Darwinian evolution I
absolutely love this definition for life
I think that everyone should adopt it
and the reason that I like it so much is
that it helps us especially when we're
studying the origin of life it helps us
focus in on a really clear easy to
remember definition that will help us
know what it is that we're looking for
now some people have expressed concern
saying that well it might be too
constricting of a definition and so it
might actually impede us from
discovering the truth about the origin
of life but to that I would just say
look you have a definition and if you
want to work within that definition you
can and if you don't like the definition
you want to prove it wrong well now
you've got this really nice neat little
definition you can go try and find
evidence for why it's wrong you can
prove it wrong treat this definition as
a working hypothesis something to be
supported or disproven so now let's just
look at this definition piece by piece
and figure out what all this stuff means
what they mean when they say that living
things are self-sustaining is that
within a specific environment a living
creature can it can hold its own right
for a bear that environment might be the
woods a bear can hold its own within the
woods for a virus that environment might
be a living cell under this definition
viruses and plasmids count as living
creatures when they say that living
things are chemical systems what they
mean here is that living things are
driven by normal chemical reactions
researchers used to think a long time
ago that there was some sort of a vital
force or a supernatural entity inside of
living things that help them be alive
that animated them but we now know that
this is not the case or at least it does
not seem to be the case the more we look
at life the more we understand life the
more we see that it's
it's just chemistry life is chemistry we
are chemical systems now if you don't
like this idea that living things or
chemical systems and you want to believe
that there's some supernatural or
unknown force that powers life great
prove us wrong and we'll have to
redefine this definition you will be
famous last but not least living things
are capable of Darwinian evolution and
what we mean here is that because living
things reproduce they make copies of
themselves natural selection can select
for or against different variations of
those copies allowing living creatures
to adapt to their environment across
multiple generations this is why living
things are so good at getting along
within a specific environment because
they've evolved to get along in that
environment descent with modification
acted upon by selection equals Darwinian
evolution so there you have it
life is a self-sustaining chemical
system capable of Darwinian evolution I
love this definition because it allows
us to include viruses and plasmids and
that definition and also because it
makes us ask some really strange
questions it makes us think about life
in new ways for example is a single
person a living thing because according
to this definition you know I all by
myself cannot evolve
I cannot reproduce right but you see
there in the definition capable of
Darwinian evolution I am capable of
finding a mate and then reproducing and
therefore evolving but then what about
what about an older woman that's gone
through menopause and she can no longer
reproduce does that mean that she's no
longer alive well of course not because
her cells are reproducing all the time
and her cells are evolving all the time
hopefully not too quickly because too
much cellular evolution can give rise to
cancer but of course she is a living
creature her cells at least fit the bill
so what is life life is a
self-sustaining chemical system capable
of Darwinian evolution
next question